[Music]
so pretty much everyone knows that one
guy who on New Year's Eve proclaims to
all his friends his ambitious plans to
go to the gym everyday or wake up at 7
a.m.
every morning for the whole year and
they go and buy new workout clothes
install habit tracking apps and are
elated by the prospect of becoming that
awesome person they've always wanted to
be in fact they're so excited about it
it's as if they actually you know did
something but before a single day is
completed they'll bombard you with
incessant monologues about all the
benefits they're going to experience and
how life-changing it's gonna be but you
almost can't help but roll your eyes
because you know they're just talking
about it not actually doing it one of
the things I've learned over the years
is that nobody cares about what you say
you're going to do and you shouldn't
either no matter how much you flap your
jaw nothing moves and having ambition
isn't special almost everyone has
ambition whatever your goal in life is
there are likely millions of other
people with that exact same goal unless
you have like a really weird goal like
performing a puppet show on top of Mount
Everest or something but telling
somebody that you're going to do
something isn't impressive to anyone in
any way and never has been and it never
will be
so instead of humble bragging to your
roommate about how you're gonna start
taking the gym more seriously or start
eating clean from now on try giving your
tongue a little rest and actually get a
few days weeks or even months under your
belt learn to embrace the process of
pushing yourself and achieving things
when nobody is watching because after
all who are you doing this for anyways
do you genuinely want to build a company
or do you just crave the patronizing oh
that's cool man good for you then you
get for mentioning it the way I see it
there are only four types of people in
this world those who talk the talk and
walk the walk those who talk the talk
and don't walk the walk those who don't
talk the talk and don't walk the walk
and finally those who don't talk the
talk but walk the walk and I would argue
that this final option
is the best option you should strive
towards because those who talk the talk
and walk the walk are usually annoying
and they brag about the fact that they
do things those who talk the talk and
don't walk the walk are even worse
because they pretend that they do all
these things but they're just talking
and the saddest of the bunch number
three are those who don't talk the talk
and don't walk the walk
pretty self-explanatory yeah just a
generally uninspiring crowd to be around
and number for those who don't talk to
talk but walk the walk these are the
coolest people on planet earth this is
the guy who's absolutely ripped but
doesn't talk about it the guy who drives
an insanely nice car but few people know
what he does for a living
his lifestyle is proof in and of itself
of rigorous discipline hard work
patience etc but he doesn't flaunt it
unless it's with a legitimate
accountability partner or group that you
actually take seriously speaking before
you do is just a useless step in the way
of actually doing otherwise you're just
seeking validation for something you
haven't even done yet so here's a
personal challenge from me
go achieve something you've always
wanted to achieve something you've been
putting off for a long time and
something that would dramatically
improve your life and when you're done
don't tell a soul
I guarantee you this will improve the
way you look at yourself
it will bolster your self-efficacy
you'll carry around this confidence it's
like your own dirty little secret and
it'll permeate every aspect of your
being your interactions with other
people and you'll secretly know that
you're a badass
and you didn't have to tell anybody if
you liked this video be sure to hit that
like button
and if you like videos like these in
general hit that subscribe button if
you're a regular subscriber you might be
confused that you're not seeing my face
at the end of this video
basically I'm having a bad hair day know
basically half my apartment is packed up
and the background looks really bad so I
just figured I'd keep it yeah you get it
next video you might see my face talking
to the camera okay see you later
[Music]